war weltweit im netz die brutalität zu
eindeutig und doch spricht die russische
seite von einer inszenierung der krieg
in der ukraine ist auch zu einer
schlacht um fakten und lügen geworden
zwischen wahrheit und propaganda der
krieg und die medien darüber sprechen
wir heute in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen ich begrüße sie aus
berlin und ich freue mich über diese
gäste deniz yücel ist bei uns als
korrespondent der welt und präsident des
pen-zentrums deutschland und wegen
seiner journalistischen arbeit ist das
eher 2017 ein jahr in haft in der türkei
professor doktor sönke neitzel begrüße
ich herzlich er ist militär historiker
an der universität in potsdam und
herzlich willkommen susanne koelbl sie
ist auslands reporterin beim spiegel
berichtet seit über 30 jahren aus vielen
krisenregionen der welt unter anderem
aus afghanistan syrien und auch vom
balkan jetzt willkommen georg mascolo
begrüße ich autor der süddeutschen
zeitung bis vor kurzem leiter des
recherche verbundes von 70 süddeutscher
zeitung ndr und wdr als reporter bei im
ersten golfkrieg im irak und in syrien
unterwegs und zugeschaltet ist uns
katrin eigendorf vom zdf sie ist jetzt
in der ukraine war zuvor korrespondentin
in moskau hat auch langjährige erfahrung
als reporterin unter anderen in
afghanistan und tschetschenien und
später schalten wir auch noch zum
kollegen der für die ard aus der ukraine
berichtet georg restle aber bevor wir
jetzt hier in die diskussion einsteigen
ein kurzer überblick über fake und
fakten der letzten wochen in diesem
krieg das bietet ihnen philipp wunder
sehen
ein krieg zwischen wahrheit und
desinformation
wir planen nicht andere länder zu
überfallen wir haben auch nicht die
ukraine überfallen jeder krieg auch eine
propagandaschlacht
kriegsverbrechen sind nicht möglich ohne
propagandisten die sie vertuschen
bilder aus butter einem vorort von kiew
erschüttern die welt sie sollen belegen
dass russische soldaten viele zivilisten
getötet haben die ukrainische regierung
wirft russland ein massaker vor und
spricht von völkermord russland dagegen
streitet die verantwortung ab spricht
von einer inszenierung und gezielter
provokation
diese bilder machen schlagzeilen ein
vermeintlicher angriff russischer
truppen auf eine entbindung heimen mario
pohl bilder verletzter schwangerer
frauen menschen werden getötet und
verletzt sagt der bürgermeister im
russischen staatsfernsehen ist das
gebäude gar kein krankenhaus und die
verletzte schwangere eine schauspielerin
eine vermeintliche explosion in der
ukraine
tausendfach geteilten netz angeblich als
beleg für russische bomben in der
ukraine aber eigentlich eine explosion
in china vor sieben jahren
und nein dieses video zeigt keine
leichensäcke in der ukraine
es zeigt einen klima protest aus wien es
wurde manipuliert und gezielt verbreitet
wie auch dieses dieb fake video im netz
kursiert der manipulierte clip in dem
präsident sie lenski die ukrainer sofort
zur kapitulation aufruft
wenn bilder und videos zu waffen werden
der krieg auch eine schlacht um die
deutungshoheit stirbt die wahrheit
zuerst
ja welche wahrheit war das da in guca
die russen sprechen von einer
inszenierung wir schalten gleich so
katrin eigendorf von grad ein bisschen
probleme mit der leitung hat man sie die
frage herr mascolo denn die russen von
einer inszenierung sprechen durch
ukrainer man auf der anderen seite ganz
klar tote dort sieht als reporterin ja
wie geht man damit um das ist die
wahrheit
dann geht man damit um wie in allen
anderen solchen konflikten und kriegen
zuvor irgendwie auch das ist ja nicht
das erste mal dass wir wissen dass krieg
und lüge tatsächliche zwillinge sind es
auf jeden fall in die und ich glaube in
jedem fall ist das ganz offenkundig die
russische seite vor allem und schon vor
beginn des krieges angefangen hat mit
einer fülle von falschbehauptungen fing
damit an dass sie gesagt haben sie
hätten überhaupt nicht wo die ukraine zu
überfallen operiert hat das ist die
aufgabe von journalismus ich bin dankbar
für die vielen kolleginnen und kollegen
die dort vor ort sind und ihre arbeit
machen sie eine ganz ungewöhnliche
situation auch für unseren berufsstand
müssen welche dort hin die sich den
gleichen risiko aussetzen wie es die
zivilbevölkerung erlebt oder auch
soldatinnen und soldaten um so gutes
denn irgend geht den dingen auf den
grund zu gehen und ich bin sehr sicher
dass wir bald wissen werden was in
butter und all den anderen orten
geschehen ist und wir werden es wissen
durch internationale untersuchung durch
hoffentlich untersuchungen des
kriegsverbrechertribunals und wie so oft
durch die arbeit von journalistinnen und
journalisten die vor ort sind
augenzeugenberichte sammeln und ich bin
sehr sicher dass die wahrheit die ganze
wahrheit dessen was sind der ukraine an
diesem und ich fürchte auch an anderen
orten geschehen ist bald zu tage treten
wird die indizien um auch dass zusagen
sind aus meiner sicht ganz eindeutig und
sie zeigen in richtung auf russland wer
ich höre jetzt dass frau eigentlich
zugeschaltet ist katrin eigendorf wir
haben eben darüber gesprochen hat eben
welche wahrheit man denn ja welche weit
haben sie in butter gesehen weil das ist
ja wird ja angezweifelt weil wie würden
sie sagen wenn man sagt im krieg stirbt
die wahrheit immer so erst zuerst was
welche weit haben sie dort gesehen
ich finde den begriff wahrheit
problematisch weil im prinzip gibt es
keine wahrheit es gibt perspektiven auf
die realität und es gibt fakten und
natürlich blickt jeder mit einer anderen
perspektive auf die realität deswegen
ist es ja so wichtig auch verschiedene
augenzeugen hier vor ort zu haben aber
was mir natürlich unterscheiden müssen
das was russland uns präsentiert ist
keine perspektive auf die realität und
deswegen stehen wir jedem vor dem
problem dass wir eigentlich mit dem
journalistischen prinzip dass man immer
bei einem konflikt verschiedene
perspektiven und seiten darstellen muss
das wird ist eigentlich gar nicht tun
können weil wir müssten ja dann lügen
gegen realität präsentieren und deswegen
glaube ich ist es ungemein wichtig dass
wir als journalisten hier als
augenzeugen vor ort sind was ich in
butter gesehen habe sind schwere
kriegsverbrechen ich habe dort mit
menschen gesprochen die mir geschildert
haben wie russische soldaten zivilisten
beschossen haben wie sie wohnungen und
geschäfte geplündert haben wie sie
frauen entführt und vergewaltigt haben
und die städte die wir gesehen haben
bieten ein bild unglaublicher zerstörung
also ich habe eine solches ein solches
ausmaß von zerstörung in meiner
beruflichen laufbahn
selten an einem ort so konzentriert
gesehen also auch das ganz klar in
wohnhäuser auf kindergärten auf
spielplätze gefeuert wurde
das dokumentiert doch dass das was
russland hier sagt anne lüge ist also
die von einer inszenierung zu sprechen
das empfinden natürlich die ukraine bei
all dem schmerz den sie ihr leben als
noch einmal eine weitere eskalation das
ist ein informationskrieg indem wir
journalisten als augenzeugen glaube ich
eine ungemein große rolle spielen jetzt
haben sie selbst gesagt dass es sind
dinge an sie sind eine erfahrene
reporterin die schlimmer sind als vieles
was sie bisher gesehen haben wie wie
viel emotionen ist da erlaubt wie
schafft man es dann trotzdem ja sehr
sachlich und nüchtern letztendlich zu
berichten
ich denke es ist wichtig dass man
emotionen zulässt weil gute
berichterstattung muss immer eine
mischung aus verstand und herz sein also
ohne empathie
kommt man ja den menschen auch nicht
mehr sie können ja nicht an
journalistischer roboter design der die
menschen praktisch ab fragt nach ihren
erlebnissen sie müssen schon teilhaben
an dem und ich glaube es ist auch
wichtig dinge
nachzuvollziehen und ist auch wichtig
als reporter selber den schmerz
zuzulassen der mit dem ganzen einhergeht
was wir hier erleben ich empfinde das
als sehr schmerzhaft was ich hier erlebe
in den letzten wochen für den zuschauer
ist es glaube ich wichtig ist
transparent zu machen das ist
transparent ist transparent zu machen
unter welchen bedingungen wir arbeiten
ja das ist zum beispiel
viele touren hier vom innenministerium
geführt werden dass man uns irgendwo hin
bringt uns gelegenheit gibt mit menschen
zu sprechen
transparent zu machen in welcher rolle
man hier auch selber als reporter agiert
das ist glaube ich wäre echte
berichterstattung und dann muss die
natürlich immer auf fakten basieren
sehen sie da eine gefahr dass sie da
irgendwie auch vereinnahmt werden
oder werden könnten weil sie halt eben
natürlich abhängig sind davon dass das
innenministerium da sie dadurch führt
man die gefahr sehe ich nicht also das
ist ja ein kriegsgebiet wo es auch
relativ schwierig ist an diese orte
heran zu kommen wir haben zum beispiel
heute eine fahrt nach ihn auf eigene
faust unternommen das war wirklich sehr
schwierig wir haben so lange im stau
festgesteckt weil ihr herrscht ein
totales chaos dass ich fast hier auch zu
spät zu der sendung gekommen wäre
es ist schon gut in begleitung von
regierungsstellen hierzu ist vor ort zu
sein weil es ist ja auch ein gewisser
schutz damit verbunden und ich habe
jetzt vier tage hier erlebt dass wir in
begleitung des innenministeriums uns
orte angucken konnten und mit menschen
sprechen konnten und man hat uns da
keinerlei restriktionen auferlegt also
es ist ja nicht so gewesen dass man uns
gesagt hat ihr müsst mit denen und den
leuten sprechen oder dass jemand neben
uns gestanden hätte ja das wäre
kontrollierte berichterstattung im
rahmen eines krieges und an krieg
limitiert journalismus immer alleine
durch die gefahr der weniger ausgesetzt
sind aber im rahmen eines
kriegszustandes denke ich können wir
hier relativ frei berichten
frau koelbl wie sie bleiben im moment
bei uns frau eigendorf dann reden wir
gleich auf jeden fall noch weiter
mischen sie sich bitte gerne auch ein
frau koelbl sie haben eben auch als
auslands reporterin ja lange berichtet
wenn wir das gerade gehört dass frau
eigendorf gehört man muss die emotionen
schon zu lassen es sind dinge die ein
natürlich unglaublich berühren wie ist
ihnen das gegangen in ihrem beruflichen
leben und wo würden sie sagen ist dass
gerade ganz wichtig die emotionen
zuzulassen und auf der anderen seite
aber vielleicht auch zu sagen jetzt muss
ich professionell agieren auch um mich
etwas mehr zu schützen
also mit der emotion verhält es sich
folgendermaßen wir länger sie an einem
ort sind je mehr sie mit menschen zu tun
haben und länger zu tun haben die sie
auch dann länger kennen desto
schwieriger wird das diese distanz zu
halten
gleichzeitig glaube ich dass das
entscheidende er das zuhören ist
menschen zuhören und was sie brauchen
ist ein gewissen menschlichkeit um dich
leuten zu nähren die diesen schmerz
erlebt haben
ich glaube schon dass es eine mischung
ist aus empathie und professionalität
aber am ende
müssen wir diese profis bleiben also ich
habe festgestellt zum beispiel wenn man
lange lange lange in einem gebiet ist
ich habe sehr lange über afghanistan zum
beispiel berichtet tut das immer noch
da fällt es dann zunehmend schwer diese
distanz zu halten und ich würde mal
denken dass man irgendwann mal in die
gefahr läuft ob sie auf die andere seite
zu kippen und
das leid irgendwann mal auch bewältigen
zu wollen und das geht nun wirklich
nicht
da haben wir in unsere professionalität
grenzen die wir auch verstehen und
einhalten sollten also journalisten
müssen ihre rolle genau wissen und
kennen und sie haben gesagt man sie
müssen im profil bleiben wie würden sie
es beurteilen was ist das wichtigste
wenn man in einer ja in einem solchen
extremsituation ist um auch frau
eigentlich wird sie findet dass worten
wahrheit eigentlich nicht so ganz
richtig aber um bei den fakten zu
bleiben ich glaube jetzt mit leistung
den kolleginnen und kollegen hier ist
meine erfahrung ein persönlicher
erfahrung als kriegsberichterstatter
hält sich in grenzen ich mach mal in
syrien in den kurdischen region in der
türkei in der südosttürkei als es zu
bewaffneten auseinandersetzung kam aber
ich bin ich war nie wirklich
kriegsberichterstatter von daher würde
ich nicht bei der frage zurückhaltend
aber nicht wenn sie erlauben wenn ich
etwas anderes sagen und zwar habe ich
den eindruck dass sie diese diskussion
wie wir sie jetzt gerade auch angefangen
haben und wir sind den letzten tagen
geführt wird das ist jetzt keine kritik
an sie oder an der sendung sondern
einfach eine bestandsaufnahme haben wir
eine merkwürdige situation dass in dem
moment wo die größten verbrechen des
land bekannten verbrechen der russischen
seite auf die zusagen sichtbar werden
ich habe mir eine lebende eine
verdrehung also es wäre jetzt eigentlich
der moment zu fragen wie kann die
weltgemeinschaft die musik künftig mit
diesem russland umgehen und stattdessen
reden wir darum ob die die idee tegra ob
die bilder ob das was ob das was aus
butter und anderen orten berichtet wird
ob das wahr ist das ist wirklich ein
bemerkenswerter propagandaerfolg der
russischen seite und ich habe mir jetzt
in den letzten wochen habe ich mir die
mühe gemacht
voran medien sehr genau zu beobachten
sei es jetzt an teilen der linkspartei
oder der afd da sind die sehr als putin
verstehe gelten auch deshalb weil die
nicht nur weil sie an den rändern sind
sondern weil sie vielleicht auch schon
immer sachen bisschen deutlicher und
stärker formuliert haben als wir dann
auch in anderen kreisen gedacht wird und
das sind und da war fand ich interessant
also bei so einer zeitung wie der junge
welt super spielt diaz am 23 februar das
war der tag genau der takt zwischen dem
einmarsch dem russischen einmarsch in
dombach und dem angriff auf die gesamte
ukraine haben sie die titelzeile
gebracht putin erzwingt frieden das muss
man erst mal hinkriegen putin erzwingt
frieden ähnlich war es bei all den
kreisen und danach nachdem sie haben
offenbart man auch in diesen kreisen
nicht damit gerechnet dass die routine
ganze dass russland die ukraine
angreifen würde danach war das kein
rechten defensiv auch was man so auf den
entsprechenden von den entsprechenden
auf dem flügel der linkspartei gehört
hat auf der afg und so weiter und jetzt
mit dem moment wo eigentlich deckt das
dieses diese diese furchtbaren bilder zu
sehen sind in dem moment das ist
wirklich eine bemerkenswerte auch
zynische wendung in dem moment das ist
das erste mal wo die quasi wieder in die
offensive gehen und in der jungen welt
oder in anderen anschlägen medien wird
genau diese frage diskutiert ob diese
bilder überhaupt vase interessiert in
frage gestellt und das finde ich
wirklich an bemerkenswerten propaganda
erfolg der russischen seite dass wir
hier nicht über konsequenzen aus diesen
wird er werde jetzt gar nicht jenen
ländern oder allgemein wird aber erst
mal darüber gesprochen wird es überhaupt
ob das überhaupt richtig ist nicht
einmal das einschätzung das ist auch
wenn wir jetzt nicht alles wissen im
detail aber die die alles was jetzt
schon bekannt ist das ist ganz eindeutig
dass ich glaube dass ich hier zwei
ebenen a.de
überlagern ich habe es ja gesagt ich
glaube dass die indizien die heute schon
auf dem tisch liegen dass sie geradezu
zwingend sind wir wissen seit heute
durch die unterrichtung des
bundesnachrichtendienstes der
entsprechenden parlamentarischen gremien
das ganz offensichtlich auf funksprüche
zur verfügung steht die jetzt den
generalbundesanwalt zur verfügung stellt
wird das heißt ich habe keinen zweifel
dass an der stelle und jetzt können wir
über die frage streiten wann haben wir
letztlich ein komplettes bild und kann
man an einem solchen tag wie heute schon
sagen alles deutet darauf hin und
deswegen müssen wir über die
konsequenzen sprechen
des barbarischen verhaltens russlands
ich würde sagen so schrecklich diese
bilder sind das ehrlich gesagt mit
welchem land wir es da zu tun haben wie
tiefes gesunken es ist doch etwas was
wir zuvor schon wussten ich erlebe
geradezu die jetzige zeit sie haben es
gesagt dass sie ja selbst diejenigen die
die russland verstehen erklären wollten
dass man doch im moment sieht dass sie
in deckung laufen und an manchen fällen
geradezu entdeckung sprinten müssen weil
doch dieser russische propaganda apparat
in den vergangenen vergangenen wochen
und monaten so hoch gedreht hat und
dabei und erfolgreiche ich glaube nicht
hervor sondern ich glaube dass er ja in
wahrheit dabei immer tiefer sinkt dass
es die lügen werden doch für jeden der
sehen will werden sie doch immer
offenkundiger wir sind doch jetzt
angekommen bei das
bernhard-nocht-institut in hamburg ein
institut für tropenmedizin entwickelt
biowaffen mit den usa um russland gern
zugreifen es sind einfach noch mal dabei
erneut zu wenn sie jetzt setzt diese die
bilder aus bush haben viele gesagt ist
es nochmal ein wendepunkt in dem krieg
jetzt muss man es noch mal schärfere
sanktionen mann war für viele das große
entsetzen also welche rolle spielen
bilder ja in der kriegsführung also
medien spielen in der kriegsführung seit
hunderten von jahren das ist immer die
antwort wenn sie den drucker fragen
natürlich eine ganz entscheidende rolle
wir haben immer unterschiedliche medien
also der spanische bürgerkrieg war der
erste krieg des kinos der zweite
weltkrieg dann wochenschauen der
vietnamkrieg des fernsehens der
golfkrieg das internet und jetzt haben
wir den social media krieg aber alle
kriege der moderne waren auch
medienereignisse jetzt haben wir die
geschwindigkeit hat sich erhöht und ich
finde also ich nehme zumindest die
öffentliche diskussion so war das
ähnlich wie cross wir eigentlich keine
zweifel haben was passiert ist ich nehme
auch wahr dass das mutter zu einem
größeren druck führt aber man kann eben
auch manchmal einen quickie und da ein
fragezeichen machen ich erinnere daran
an den kosovo-krieg dass die massaker
die in ganz entscheidend das eingreifen
der nato getriggert durch ein bbc
reporter
er sagte das ist ein massaker an
kosovo-albanern von serbischen
sicherheitskräften bis heute nicht klar
ist wer das nicht wirklich war und die
und die also das ist jetzt aus meiner
sicht hier nicht so der fall aber wir
wissen schon dass die debatte bengasi zu
elf es wird ein genozid geben durch
gaddafi viele stellen dass im zweifel
also dass man schon auch mal schaut ich
glaube gut und böse sind in diesem klick
aus meiner sicht klar verteilt trotzdem
beginnt auch ukrainer kriegsverbrechen
nicht in der dimension nach meiner
kenntnis ist noch mal gut und böse sind
verteilt aber natürlich wird auch die
ukraine 1 1 1 fremming sagen durch was
man sich da gelegentlich mal einfach nur
mal zurücktritt und nochmal schüttelt
und sagt
wie sieht das aus überprüfung und hier
ist es aus meiner sicht völlig eindeutig
und ich würde noch eines sagen das wäre
meines wissens ebensolche solche
gräueltaten in der ersten woche nicht
gesehen haben und ich habe auch mit den
entsprechenden sicherheitskreisen
gesprochen habt ihr erkenntnisse sogar
krieg ist ein verbrechen ich brauche die
obwohl mario pohl ist ein verbrechen
überhaupt die erkenntnisse über die
erschießung von kriegsgefangenen und
ermordung von zivilisten in größerer
zahl massaker so und dann sagt man dem
mann ein und ich glaube schon dass alle
vielleicht fragen
wir haben wir haben ein abo dass das
befürchteten und jetzt ist eben ja aus
meiner sicht der beweis praktisch da
dass wir das sehen was wir alle
befürchtete ja frau eigendorf wie würden
sie das sagen aus der beobachtung des
krieges jetzt in die ganze zeit ist das
noch mal eine andere qualität klingt so
bemerkt wurde ja eine andere kategorie
spricht das für eine bestimmte strategie
das was wir gesehen haben in butter in
dieser kriegsführung
die strategie war er von vornherein klar
was putin will putin spricht dem
ukrainischen folgte dem der ukraine als
staat ja ihre existenz ab er sieht sie
als teil russlands erhält die
demokratisch gewählte regierung der
ukraine
das hat er in einem fast schon gossen
joe cornish beschrieben als eine bande
von nazis und drogensüchtigen wir
erleben aber natürlich hier jetzt in dem
moment
wo die truppen aus einem besetzten
gebiet sich zurückziehen oder
zurückgeschlagen wurden was dort
geschieht und geschehen ist das ist ja
ein mario pohl im moment nur sehr sehr
schwer möglich weil dort haben
journalisten ja eigentlich kaum zugänge
das heißt wir haben jetzt hier die
möglichkeit wirklich ganz klar nach zu
recherchieren was ist passiert wir
können mit menschen sprechen man kann
leichen identifizieren also man kann
hier wirklich
nachvollziehen welche kriegsverbrechen
die russen begangen haben und ich würde
hier schon jetzt von kriegsverbrechen
sprechen weil darauf deuten ja nun viele
dinge hin wie zum beispiel die tatsache
dass sie wohnhäuser kindergärten
beschossen haben das ist ja unstrittig
das kann man ja auch sehen ich würde
gerne noch mal den blick zurück wenden
dieser krieg dauert ja seit 2014 und wir
erleben ja jetzt wie viele politiker
zurückrücken und sagen ja wir haben
russland idealisiert es war falsch über
nord stream zwei nachzudenken ich sehe
hier wenig bei uns journalisten
mal selbstkritik über wie wir mit der
ukraine umgegangen sind ich war selber
als journalistin
2014/2015 auch die jahre danach immer
wieder in der ukraine und das ziel
russlands in diesem meiner meinung nach
ersten großen informationskrieg der
jüngeren geschichte war immer auch
journalisten zu diskreditieren unsere
berichterstattung in frage zu stellen
und dem haben sich diesen dieser
infragestellung haben sich viele in
deutschland angeschlossen und wir haben
ja in den redaktionen auch debatten
darüber geführt
stellen wir jetzt die position der
russen darstellen wir die position der
ukraine da es war die rede davon diese
diskussion haben wir geführt dass hier
faschisten in der ukraine am werk sind
also etwas was überhaupt nicht durch die
realitäten belegt ist wir haben uns über
jahre in den redaktionen unter dem zwang
der vermeintlichen objektive russlands
propaganda russlands sprech zu eigen
gemacht und ich sehe jetzt eine gefahr
dass wir das wieder machen wenn wir
jetzt hingehen und sagen oh
jetzt müssen wir aber auch mal gucken ob
das was herr labor auf sagt vielleicht
richtig ist jetzt müssen wir die ukraine
mal infrage stellen also ich bin da 100
prozent bei denise witschel ich empfinde
das geradezu als
beschämend in frage zu stellen was hier
passiert ist und so zu tun als müsste
die ukraine ist ein nachweis dafür
liefern dass sie diese verbrechen hier
nicht inszeniert also
das finde ich entsetzlich ja würde ich
gerne mal hier dann direkt weil wir
aufnehmen würden sie dem zustimmen dass
vereine aufgelöst und das wir seit 2014
eigentlich und die aufgabe als
journalisten da nicht wirklich
wahrgenommen zunächst mal würde ich
gerne sagen wollen dass die ukraine
natürlich nicht den beweis erbringen
muss was eigentlich dort geschehen ist
oder nicht sondern man argument wenn ich
mich erinnere war das jetzt alles getan
werden muss alle hintergründe dieses und
weiterer verbrechen von denen ich
befürchtete sie begangen worden sind
aufzuklären dass das eine aufgabe für
journalistinnen und journalisten und für
alle anderen es weil ehrlich gesagt wir
sehen hier das foto von wladimir putin
aber ehrlich gesagt gibt es im
völkerrecht auch eine klare
verantwortlichkeit für diejenigen die
geschossen haben für diejenigen die
diese gräueltaten begangen haben für
diejenigen die in der kommandokette
darüber stehen und das beginnt im grunde
im feld selbst das heißt in diesen orten
und reicht bis in den kreml
na ja wir waren ehrlich gesagt noch nie
eine branche die gut darin gewesen ist
selbstkritisch zurück zu gucken und ich
kann mich ehrlich gesagt ja ja ja und da
ich das lange genug machen kann ich das
auch aus eigener erfahrung sagen wir
sind immer sehr gut da drin wenn
irgendwas schiefgeht zu sagen das hätte
man doch erstens sofort sehen müssen das
war ja alles irgendwie schon völlig klar
und ich habe immer gewusst und billy
verantwortung liegt bei wem auch immer
aber ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt ein
praktisch keine große fehlentwicklungen
der letzten jahre erinnern wo man nicht
eigentlich genau so offen und ehrlich
über die frage diskutieren müsste
welchen anteil hat daran eigentlich ein
teil des journalismus' gab und dann wird
man praktisch immer was finden und ich
glaube bei der ukraine hat katrin
eigendorf völlig recht es fing schon mit
solchen formulierungen an wie der
ukraine krise wo er immer so ein
bisschen mitschwang
in der ukraine gibt es irgendeine krise
die hatte ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
gegeben das land ist irgendwie
überfallen war und so das ist das erste
mal 2014 und dann später mit dem was wir
in der ost ukraine erlebt haben das
heißt schon unsere wortwahl ja nicht
hinreichend präzise gewesen hat von ich
beschrieben um was es eigentlich
wirklich geht ich glaube das ist eine
zweite platte kurz darauf hin zu
bitten entschuldigung entschuldigung ich
würde ja gerne kurz hinzufügen bin ich
völlig der mahnung nicht nur das wir
ewig lange und bis jetzt teilweise noch
von einem konflikt in der ukraine
sprechen es wurde ja dieser krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine auch im
prinzip als bürgerkrieg bezeichnet man
alleine diese formulierung von russland
unterstützte separatisten als hätte ist
jemals in der ukraine eine ernsthafte
separatisten bewegung gegeben bevor
russland diesen krieg hier geführt hat
russland hat einfach die ukraine
angegriffen und sich teile der
ukrainischen bevölkerung zu eigen
gemacht um diesen krieg zu führen aber
das war nie ein krieg der
von russland unterstützte separatisten
gegen die regierung gekämpft haben lange
diese wortwahl ist falsch herr neitzel
ist dass die ja ist das sozusagen die
naivität der journalisten dass sie das
übernehmen oder ist es die die klugheit
der russischen propaganda warum kann das
so funktionieren ich glaube das hat ganz
viel mit unserem referenzrahmen zu tun
dass sie einfach alle
also vielleicht die historiker oder die
militärs drücke ausgegangen dass viele
journalisten politiker nicht wahrhaben
wollen dass krieg geführt wird und dass
der krieg im referenzrahmen keine rolle
spielt wenn ich das wahrnehmen dass da
krieg geführt wird muss soll ja auch
konsequenzen ziehen und die wir haben
dort die zeit von 2 14 bis jetzt in
einer art wolkenkuckucksheim gelebt wo
man sich wirklich die augen reibt weil
man die konsequenzen gefürchtet hat und
das hat man semantische ausgedrückt wenn
man von krieg von angriffskrieg damals
schon gesprochen hätte während ja auch
die konsequenzen hätte man zwei solche
sachen nicht machen können und wir haben
den krieg seit 30 jahren aus unseren
referenzrahmen ausgeschlossen und sind
am 24 februar aufgebracht dann bekommst
du dich wohl wer auch im krieg auf dem
balkan hatten aber auch der wird ja er
wird in einer merkwürdigen weise wir
reden über die 90er jahre als leiter des
friedens da fragt man sich frieden muss
dann für den frieden wird es ja nicht
also das hat mit der deutschen erfahrung
zu tun und so ein bisschen
wolkenkuckucksheim mal wird das nicht
wahrnehmen weil man sich sagen nicht
nicht stören lassen will in seiner
bestimmtes spezifischen weltwahrnehmung
ist es auch ihre erfahrung frau koelbl
dass man einfach davor schreckt und dass
man dann ja eigentlich nicht gerne das
sind klare worte auch fast also es gibt
auf jeden fall für dieses land zu
deutschland ist ein lang das keineswegs
also eigentlich ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen ihre eigentlich wenn ich das
böse nicht denke dann passiert es
vielleicht auch nicht ja es war in
afghanistan schon so und das war
wahrscheinlich auch in auf den ball
können so und hier ist auf jeden fall so
also wenn ich wenn ich informationen und
erkenntnisse habe wie sie herr
vorgelegen haben nicht nur sein 2014 an
durchgehend
und dann 5000 helme liefern möchte ist
es ungefähr so wie wenn ich im bitteren
kalten winter in afghanistan 5000 teller
liefern dass man dass man was man
wirklich glaubt man könnte indem man
sich nicht positioniert
die krise aufhalten und ist natürlich
der fall
als damals der verteidiger eines der
guttenberg dann von krieg sprach in
afghanistan das war eine erleichterung
für die soldaten damals die von uns
geschickt waren warum war es eine
erleichterung weil das was sie erlebt
haben endlich mal auch benannt wurde
also der vergleich ist wirklich ist
wirklich signifikant weil zum beispiel
wenn ich an diese bombardierung der
tanklaster aus kunde in kunduz erinnere
warum ist das passiert dann als es ist
deshalb passiert weil die deutschen ihre
eigenen truppen so wenig ausgerüstet
haben und so wenig
und so wenige truppen geschickt haben
dass sie sich selbst nicht verteidigen
konnten und ihre eigene aufklärung nicht
organisieren konnten das hat im grund zu
dieser fehleinschätzung geführt warum
ist das passiert weil man eben keinen
krieg führen wollte weil man eben als
zivil als sabine zivil kapazität
auftreten wollte also die
nichtanerkennung des bösen im grunde und
der daraus folgenden konsequenzen für
uns natürlich
eine völlig andere ausrichtung auch
bedeuten in zukunft
selbstverteidigung aufrüstung sich
vorbereiten das land möglicherweise
beteiligen und mögliche verbündete und
schwache schwache
einheiten oder regionen verteidigen
wollen wir das können wir dass er nicht
okay ich würde sie haben es ja eben
schon angesprochen
darauf kommen warum ihrer meinung nach
die diese propaganda aus russischer
sicht dann hier dann doch verfängt wir
haben ja auch hier wir hatten
demonstrationen von pro bus tische
demonstrationen auch hier in berlin aber
ich glaube also ich wollte nur dass das
nicht falsch verstanden wird als mein
einwand eben das war jetzt keine direkte
kritik an herrn pascal oder an der
sendung einfach nur die art und weise
meine befürchtung wollte man die
befürchtung zum ausdruck bringen dass in
dem moment wo die bislang größten
russischen kriegsverbrechen
sichtbar werden dass ausgerechnet dass
russland ausgerichtet daraus
propagandaerfolg bezieht in dem man das
in frage stellt das war und so wie wir
die diskussion jetzt gefühlt haben das
meinte ich mit dass wege defensiv
darüber reden
das wollte ich nur
ich glaube ich glaube mit der
demonstration ich würde erstmal war denn
bevor wir zu den zu den kleinen
prorussischen demonstrationen kommen du
dich gern etwas zu den großen zu der
großen demonstration sagen ich war auch
da als teilnehmer auch einfach so nicht
als berichterstatter nicht als redner
einfach als teilnehmer an dieser großen
demonstration am großen stern und was
ich dann was dann später so dann kommen
die dann auch berichte berichtet wurde
als eigentlich auch recht klein das dann
zum beispiel dass eine gruppe vom dass
die leute junge ukrainische
berlinerinnen und berliner auch keine
nationalisten sondern eher
linksgerichtete aktivisten die schon den
neunten sie schon im januar die ersten
proteste in berlin organisiert haben als
in der die bundesregierung und viele
andere dachten putin habe seine armee so
zum picknicken hat die russische grenze
geschickt dass genau die leute da dahin
nicht eingelassen ausgeladen wurden von
der veranstaltung weil die gesagt weil
die für waffenlieferungen waren das war
in deutschland damals dass man noch das
war am tag genau an den tag an
urlaubsorten vor der zeitenwende sprache
weil die für eine flugverbotszone waren
und ich habe seither bei diesen großen
demonstration bei diesen bei dieser
ganzen anteilnahme und der solidarität
für die ukraine die ich wirklich toll
finde aber
bürgerinnen und bürger die dann am
berliner hauptbahnhof oder woanders
hingehen leute aufnehmen die geldspenden
das ist alles sehr ehrenwert fall als
bürgerin keine andere möglichkeit aber
in dem moment wo die politik auch viel
lieber über die flüchtlinge spricht und
was man da tun kann ja das ist und nicht
über diejenigen die die ukraine
verteidigen natürlich natürlich und das
ist so das ist auch etwas was meine
deutschland auch gerne mag man ist und
man ist so man ist
ja auch aber ich glaube ich glaube das
ist ein grundsätzliches sache in
deutschland dass wir dann auch lieber
dass man in deutschland lieber dann wohl
täter ist und die ukraine
das bedürfte als hilfsbedürftige
behandelt und nicht als politische
subjekte die bestimmte vorstellung haben
die aufforderungen haben die wünsche
haben von deutschland bund die auch
irland auch mit der waffe verteidigen
unterdessen sind wie regen wir uns
lieber als als wohltäter was finde ich
diese diese heimelige diese deutsche
blau-gelbe heimlichkeit die finde ich
die finde ich viel problematischer oder
doch mal wobei viele ja gesagt habe dass
diese zeitenwende dass ich das jetzt
könnten sie noch eine frage wann eine
app können sie noch eine frage
vielleicht beantworten fragen darf kurz
haben sie noch moment sie ist die frage
inwieweit wird diese russische
propaganda ihrer meinung nach gibt es
irgendeine möglichkeit dass jetzt wenn
man diese bilder sieht das doch in
russland so aufgenommen wird das was zu
irgendeinem jahr zu einer änderung führt
dass es doch anders gesehen wird in
russland auch
ja ich habe ein bisschen schwierigkeiten
damit wie wir auch das verhalten und die
unterstützung der russischen bevölkerung
für die politik von bleiben wladimir
putin immer auf die propaganda
reduzieren natürlich ist russland an
land in dem gibt es keine pressefreiheit
und die pressefreiheit ja gerade in den
letzten wochen noch mal ganz ganz
deutlich gelitten und es ist ein land
das propaganda betreibt par excellence
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist der ukraine
krieg der best dokumentierte krieg in
der geschichte wir haben so viele
informationen auf so vielen kanälen und
es gibt ja auch sehr viele beziehungen
zwischen ukrainern und russen und ich
erlebe hier sehr oft dass ukraine mir
sagen wir erzählen sogar unsere
familienangehörigen
wir erzählen unseren freunden in
russland was hier passiert und die
glauben das nicht sie finden den krieg
richtig also da ist schon auch eine
bloody mary putins politik findet schon
eine gewisse zustimmung unabhängig von
dieser propaganda ich mag das nicht
quantifizieren weil es sehr schwer ist
das zu quantifizieren wie viele das sind
und ich werde auch sehr vorsichtig weil
wie gesagt es ist russland mit großen
gefahren verbunden auch zu protestieren
aber was ich auch bei meinen eigenen
russischen bekannten erlebe und bei
vielen kontakten die ich in russland
habe weil ich habe dort über jahre auch
gelebt sehe ich dort schon auch eine
gewisse unterstützung und negierung der
realitäten und wir wissen das ja
mittlerweile dadurch dass wir selber in
deutschland in einer krise befunden
haben durch corona durch die querdenker
was propaganda oder was einseitige
haltung bedeutet dass sich leute nur
noch aus ihren räumen mit informationen
versorgen das ist natürlich in russland
auch ein bisschen der fall also dass das
russische volk jetzt praktisch wehrlos
der der der politischen propaganda
ausgeliefert ist und diesen krieg
deswegen unterstützt finde ich eine sehr
sehr
problematische herangehensweise ich
glaube da muss man noch viel weiter
differenzieren und viele appellieren ja
jetzt da waren also zumindest führen wir
die diskussion im zdf wir müssen auch
mehr auf russland gucken ja wir müssen
mehr auf russland gucken aber nicht
indem wir die russische perspektive
darstellen sondern indem wir uns mal
angucken wie wird denn dieser krieg im
eigenen land beschrieben wie redet putin
im land das ist nämlich noch mal ein
großer unterschied zu dem wie er
international auftritt und hätte man
sich das frühzeitig angeguckt schon in
den jahren 2014 2015 2016 hätte man
schon verstanden worauf das alles
hinausläuft das war klar man hätte conti
einfach nur mal zu hören soll das sagen
ja viele ja
okay ganz herzlichen dank frau eigendorf
für diese zeit hier und auch ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre arbeit passen
sie weiter gut auf sich aus vielen dank
frau schauen wir dann noch mal drauf
erneut wenn man das wir hätten
eigentlich noch mal genau hinhören
müssen also wenn man jetzt sagt das ist
zum einen die propaganda zum anderen ist
es einfach das was einfach mehr so
erzählt würde viele leute sind dieser
meinung auch was was gibt s was was man
dem entgegensetzen kann na ja kalt schon
knowledge das ist ein ganz großes
problem die meisten von uns sprechen
kein russisch und sehen deswegen keine
russischen medien
auch um ein eigenes fach die
osteuropäische geschichte ist jetzt
nichts dann der größte zweig der
geschichtswissenschaft und wie viel es
gibt natürlich auch journalisten
korrespondenten die reisen aber die
meisten von uns sind eben nach westen
ausgerichtet und spreche neben
italienisch französisch spanisch aber
nicht aber nicht russisch und ich glaube
schon dass diejenigen also etliche
experten auch gewarnt haben wir haben
immer alle stimmen ja schon viele
verbindungen auch es gibt ja aber kultur
das ist richtig aber trotzdem muss ich
mal sehen will hat dafür den
journalisten sprechen denn russisch also
ich glaube die meisten sprechen kein
russisch dabei meisten und dass die
eigene perspektive wird eben schon
dadurch dadurch geprägt irgend welche
sprache man spricht welches land man
sagen versteht und ich glaube unsere
unsere kompetenzen in anderen ländern
sind größer und dann ist komme ich
wieder auf mein punkt von vorhin zurück
natürlich konnte man das sehen das haben
viele leute gewarnt auch wir über den
atomkrieg in russland zum beispiel im
fernsehen gesprochen wird nur die frage
ist ist ja wie verarbeiten sie das
selber wollen sie wirklich die
konsequenzen zieht sie haben auch
afghanistan angesprochen und so wissen
konnte man das alles aber wenn man sich
selber sagt wir wollen eigentlich die
konsequenzen nicht ziehen wir haben ein
zum teil romantisches russland bild
ukraine wir wissen wenig über die
ukrainische geschichte obwohl es eine
deutsche co angels rocker kommission
gibt dann ist das relativ gut zu
erklären dass sind in den letzten jahren
weniger ein problem der gewesen ist dass
in der politik oder in weiten teilen der
medien ist tatsächlich noch ein
romantisches russland bild gegeben hat
dafür ist dann spätestens mit der
annexion der krim den gift anschlägen
auf skript einer wahlliste könnten wir
fortsetzen glaube ich dass worin sich so
viele getäuscht haben auch in unserem
berufsstand war ist es sie nicht
geglaubt haben dass putin wort für wort
und eins zu eins das wahr machen würde
was er sagt und das bringt uns ja heute
auch in diese gefährliche lage weil wir
natürlich jetzt an anderen stellen
hoffen müssen und sagen na ja aber die
nächste grenze wird er nicht
überschreiten aber jetzt können wir uns
überhaupt nicht sicher sein weil wir es
mit menschen zu tun haben der bisher
alle geräte von denen wir gedacht haben
die können auf keinen fall überschritten
werden überschritten hat sich nur einen
punkt machen die frage was die situation
in russland angeht dass sie ich sowie
katrin eigendorf die vorstellung dass
menschen in russland jetzt überhaupt
nicht wüssten was da eigentlich
passieren könnte es ist für sie sicher
sehr viel schwieriger weil diese mauer
aus propaganda dann doch sehr
professionell ist und hoch gebaut ist
das sicher lange dauern aber wir haben
ja noch einen anderen punkt in dieser
zeit würde ich argumentieren wer sehen
will kann sehen wer sehen will welch
geistes kind rtr tde die kreml
propaganda hella worauf eigentlich ist
für den sind es geradezu ein dafür
bietet es geradezu leerzeiten und man
kann nur sagen schaut es euch an merkt
es euch schaut was davon zu glauben ist
nämlich nichts und dann merkt es euch so
dass wir hoffentlich in der zukunft über
die frage kann man bestimmten russischen
medien oder dem was diesen teil der
russischen regierung kommt eigener
glauben dass wir die diskussionen in
zukunft jedenfalls ziemlich lange zeit
nicht mehr führen müssen genau welche
wrestler ist da der ist uns jetzt auch
zugeschaltet schönen guten abend georg
restle hören sie uns ja nun dafür haben
sie haben ja auch schon den anfang der
sendung mit gehört was wie weil das wir
jetzt direkt da weitermachen wo sie
waren ja auch länger korrespondent in
moskau was würden sie denn sagen wie
stark ist diese diese rolle der der
russischen propaganda würden sie dem
zustimmen was herr mascolo gesagt hat
dass man sehr wohl sich informieren kann
und dass es eine möglichkeit gibt zu
wissen wie dieser krieg abläuft
ja ausdrücklich stimmig an mascolo zu
nicht nur wie dieser krieg abläuft
sondern auch was putin mit osteuropa und
der ukraine vor hat ich bin ja seit 2010
korrespondent gewesen und habe die
großen reden von putin damals schon
gehört als er seine kulturelle hegemonie
über osteuropa in seinen reden
ausgearbeitet hat und auch dieser
ukraine krieg ist ja in dieser form
angekündigt worden von dem man hätte ihm
eben nur zuhören müssen aber mein
eindruck ist eben auch dass in vielen
deutschen medien und unter vielen
deutschen journalisten man eben nicht
zuhören wollte dass man das nicht ernst
genommen hat und dann gab es eben auch
von politischer seite durchaus das
interesse das wissen wir ja alle mit
nord stream 1 und nord stream 2 die
wirtschaftlichen verbindungen zu
russland zu stärken und ich würde ganz
grundsätzlich noch mal eins sagen also
es ist derartig evident dass es sich
hier um einen angriffskrieg handel der
per se ein völkerrechts verbrechen ist
es ist von allem was auch katrin
eigendorf erzielt hat und was wir hier
vor ort erlebt haben evident dass design
krieg ist der sich gezielt gegen die
zivilbevölkerung richtet und wer putins
krieger in syrien und in tschetschenien
sich angeschaut hat der weiß dass es zum
arsenal dieser kriegsführung von putin
gehört das genauso zu machen und ich
kann nur sagen ich bin entsetzt und
bestürzt darüber wenn ich mir angucke
was wir da an bildern gesehen haben und
was da alles in deutschland zum teil in
zweifel gezogen wird das sind furchtbare
bilder von zerstörten wohnviertel von
zerstörten einkaufszentren von
zerstörten schulen wer allen ernstes
daran zweifelt dass sich dieser krieg
gegen die zivilbevölkerung richtet er
hat nicht zugehört der hat nicht
hingeschaut genauso wenig wie herrn
putin in der vergangenheit zugehört hat
und bayern putin genau hingeschaut dann
richtig ihn von putins krieg zu sprechen
ich finde es falsch von putins krieg zu
sprechen insoweit wenn man sagt dass es
ein mann sei der für diesen krieg
verantwortlich ist natürlich ist es eine
ganze administration die dafür mit
verantwortlich ist und so sieht es ja
auch das völkerrecht und das völkerrecht
spricht er auch davon dass dann
nachgewiesen werden soll wer wo in der
kommandostruktur des militärs oder in
der politischen verantwortung der
regierung für einzelne dinge
verantwortlich gemacht wird das kennen
wir aus nürnberg und deshalb verstehe
ich das ja auch so gut dass die
ukrainische regierung hier größten wert
auf ein kriegsverbrechertribunal nach
dem vorbild nürnbergs wert legt bei
darum geht es am ende und das ist genau
der unterschied zwischen dem was die
politik macht und dem was journalisten
zu tun haben wir sind dafür da hier
beweise im sinne von fakten zu sammeln
mit leuten zu sprechen sich alles vor
ort sehr genau anzuschauen endgültige
urteile wir müssen dann von anderen
getroffen werden dafür gibt es eine
internationale justiz die am ende zu
einem schuldspruch kommen muss wir
journalisten liefern die fakten dazu
was würden sie denn sagen welche lehren
sollten ja journalisten daraus jetzt
ziehen aus diesem krieg
zu führen vielleicht später noch nicht
eine sache doch noch nein sagen die das
sieht das nicht so zu kurz kommt und
zwar die haben gerade jetzt wieder sehr
viel über russland und putin geredet ich
glaube
naja die ukraine das ist so auch
sozusagen alles als als wir alle
zusammen auch als medien in deutschland
wir haben zusammen die ukraine sehr
vernachlässigt also auch nach 2014 ich
kenne eigentlich hätte das ich kenne nur
vor ich weiß noch von einem dann dem
schulz war heute kollege von der taz der
danach wird dann in die ukraine gegangen
ist vieles was in den letzten jahren
über die ukraine gelesen habe das ist
von daniela immer wieder berichtet hat
in der taz ich glaube also bei meiner
zeitung bei der welt ist es und ich
glaube bei vielen anderen war das auch
so dass man die ukraine entweder die
korrespondenten in warschau mit
behandelt haben oder die korrespondenten
in moskau und noch mal ein wort zur
ukraine ich glaube die ukraine ist hat
nicht nur ein land am rande europas und
ein großes land am rande europas die
blut lanz sondern die ukraine ist auch
wenn man im verhältnis zu europa wenn
man sich dieses land an schaut also die
zehnerjahre das war eine zeit die
wichtig für europa insgesamt ein gutes
jahrzehnt war mit mit der euro-krise wo
sich die südeuropäischen staaten und
solidarisch
das gefühl haben unsere tage von
deutschland behandelt zu werden die
flüchtlingskrise wo die meisten
europäischen staaten an die
bundesregierung alleine gelassen haben
gewechselt und so weiter europa hat viel
an glanz zum beispiel im hinblick auf
die türkei wo anfang des jahrtausends
quasi alle das ganze das ganze land alle
verschiedenen verschiedenen spektren des
landes alle wollten nach europa um hat
ist eine ausstrahlungskraft europa hat
viel viel von dieser ausstrahlungskraft
und von der glaubwürdigkeit verloren und
ich glaube in dieser gesamt in diese
ganze tendenz der zehn jahre ist die
ukraine genau das land das gegen diese
tendenzen die ukraine war das land wo
menschen auf die straße gegangen sind wo
menschen erschossen worden für eine weil
sie für eine orientierung in richtung
europa wollten also in die ukraine ist
nicht nur an grant an land irgendwo am
rande europas sondern das ist ein land
wo europa wo die idee von europa noch
heute eine ausstrahlung hat und das ist
auch deswegen glaube ich dass europa in
der pflicht steht alles dafür zu tun die
ukraine zu verteidigen
doch die zeit schauen weil wir uns jetzt
schon auf dem bildschirm live an um die
verantwortung die die die medien da
haben und eben ob man eben etwas die
fehler die man gemacht hat ob man dass
man nicht genau hingeguckt hat dass man
das einfach vielleicht vernachlässigt
hat frau koelbl was würden sie sagen wo
es und punkt wo man sagt ja mehr
auslandsberichterstattung mehr
korrespondenten wie muss man damit
umgehen ja also ich möchte jetzt erstmal
sagen der die das thema zeitenwende ist
insofern vollkommen richtig benannt weil
auch wenn jetzt alle sagen sie hätten
alles immer schon gewusst selbst wenn
man sich diese ganzen reden angehört hat
und selbst wenn man sie richtig
verstanden hat dann war es eigentlich
bisher ausgeschlossen dass jemand über
diese rote linie geht und einen krieg
wie im 19 oder anfang zwanzigsten
jahrhundert führt es war dieses 1 gegen
durch die wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit
der gegenseitig war davon konnte man
eigentlich auch ausgehend dass das mit
was ich was 1000 verschiedenen
krisenmechanismen möglicherweise auch
funktioniert und das war ich würde mal
sagen auch mehrheitlich unterstützt dass
das der bessere weg ist als was ich was
eine feindselige in der feindselige
totale gegnerschaft zu gehen vielleicht
war das falsch aber jetzt alle zusammen
dass jetzt alle sagen uns alle wissen
das haben wir alles hätten alles wissen
und anders machen können ist eine
fehleinschätzung es war ein fehler aber
es wäre die gewünschte lage gewesen was
kann man machen um so nett was kann man
machen ehrlich gesagt die welt lernt
durchaus dazu also ich habe zum beispiel
kann ich
sagen
der ehemalige chef ankläger der un für
serie ohne der charles taylor den
diktator charles taylor hinter schloss
und riegel gebracht hat kamen gestern in
new york mit einer anklageschrift wie
können sie sofort auf den tisch legen
mit allen kommando ketten mit allen
beteiligten die für diesen krieg
verantwortlich sind es dauert nicht mehr
fünf oder zehn jahre sondern es ist
bereits da es geht schneller wenn es
geht schneller und die journalisten
natürlich ist ukraine was die
berichterstattung angeht
benachteiligt worden auch deswegen weil
wir natürlich drei krisen oder was
gleichzeitig im laufen haben haben
syrien wir haben afghanistan wir haben
jemand also selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist das sind das die
zentralen punkte und nicht wo sich etwas
anbahnt ist ist die totale konzentration
von journalisten da kann man wirklich
sagen man muss selbstkritisch sein
das trifft aber genau ist aber kann man
ihm damals anderes entgegen das würde
ich gerne auch sina fragen herr riesling
würden sie denn sagen weil das war ja
auch in der diskussion dass man jetzt
zum beispiel die russischen medien hier
rt deutsch dass man das dass man die
verbietet das wäre das wichtig und dass
wir in russisch sprach ich aus
deutschland eben noch das macht die
deutsche welle ja auch dass wir
versuchen unsere informationen hin zu
bringen
ich bin grundsätzlich sehr skeptisch
wenn es darum geht quellen zu verbieten
mir geht es eher darum eine gesellschaft
zu schaffen der klar ist was sie da vor
augen hat wenn sie russia today und
andere propaganda kanäle der euro hat es
aus dem kreml sieht ich möchte aber noch
eins sagen zu dem was gerade gesagt
worden dass ich glaube das gilt ja nicht
nur für die ukraine sondern das gilt für
ganz osteuropa wir kümmern uns
journalistisch viel zu wenig um
osteuropa wir werden möglicherweise den
nächsten krieg in den nächsten jahren in
moldawien haben und wer weiß schon in
deutschland wo moldawien überhaupt liegt
oder wie dieses land politisch
aufgestellt ist wer kennt die situation
im baltikum wer kennt die situation in
rumänien oder ungarn wirklich sehr genau
und das sind alles länder in denen sich
die zukunft europas entscheiden wird und
das sind alles länder die sehr mit sehr
großer sorge richtung moskau schauen
weil sie natürlich und zurecht sorge
haben dass dieser griff moskaus nach
osteuropa weit über die ukraine hinaus
reichen würde und ich glaube darum geht
dass es geht darum uns zu stärken
unseren journalismus zu stärken im
öffentlich rechtlichen aber auch darüber
hinaus um diese propaganda mit klaren
fakten guter berichterstattung jede
menge entgegensetzen zu können
ist das ein punkt wo man sagt dass das
ist eine gute berichterstattung ist
letztendlich auch eine ja auch eine
waffe
ja natürlich ich meine die öffentlich
rechtlichen medien werden von gebühren
finanziert sie müssen differenziert
berichten und sie müssen neue
perspektiven auf machen und wenn wir
dann nur zustimmen wenn wir sehen wie
überaus mitteleuropa berichtet wurde war
das nicht der fokus sondern man ist ein
stück weiter im fokus der regierung
gefolgt die er auf russland geschaut hat
wenn man sich die debatte ansieht war
gerade letzte woche in warschau
in polen können deutschland eigentlich
nicht verstehen warum man sich in eine
solche abhängigkeit begeben hat und wie
sehr deutschland wie der elefant im
porzellanladen die bedenken der
ostmitteleuropäischen statt einfach
beiseite gewischt hat und ich das wäre
natürlich auch ein argument gewesen
darüber wurde ja auch berichtet es gibt
halt auch im nächsten bericht immer
alles aber das argument stärker zu
machen und
aber die welt ist eben sehr kompliziert
und aus meiner sicht als wts drücke ich
drehe mich immer wieder über einen
punkten wenn wir das grundproblem war
krieg ist zusammen es auch gesagt krieg
es gar nicht möglich krieg putin das ist
schwierig leute denken wir wollten das
nicht denken und das ist genau meine
zentrale denkfehler gewesen und jetzt
ich hoffe dass in der zeitenwende die
man unterschiedlich interpretieren kann
wir so schlau geworden sind dass wir
sagen nein das ist wir müssen ihn ernst
nehmen auch andere leute ernst nehmen
krieg ist ein faktor gewesen und dass
wir hatten schon dieses diese wohlfühl
haltung auch im journalistischen bereich
auch in der wissenschaft also da sind
wir als als die einzige lernt den
einzigen lehrstoff wird man die tiere
nicht besser ich habe ja wirklich gesagt
habe wir sollten vielleicht mehr
bundeswehr haben die einsatzbereit ist
oder auch kriegs bereit dann hat man
mich manchmal also eine rechtsradikale
ecke gestellt jetzt sieht man das auch
anders also wir müssen und das ist ein
entscheidender faktor gewesen da haben
es uns zu bequem gemacht und das haben
die polen und die balten anlass gesehen
die haben mich wirklich angst gehabt wir
haben diese ängste nicht wirklich ernst
gleich heißt das er muss cool oder wenn
man es auf den journalismus überträgt
das heißt wir müssen auch viel mehr
krisen reporter kriegsreporter haben
menschen die das auch können und die das
lesen können ich würde ehrlich gesagt
schon mal ein stück vorher anfangen
wollen es ist ja kein mangel daran werde
nirgendwo krise oder krieg ist dann sehe
ich ehrlich gesagt völlig egal ob in der
tage seite wurde im fernsehen dann geht
es irgendwie von morgens bis abends ich
würde mir ehrlich gesagt wünschen dass
wir dann doch mit einer anderen konstanz
das machen was irgendwie guter
journalismus ausmacht nämlich irgendwie
da hinzuschauen wo sich entwicklungen
anbauen könnten zu sagen hier lohnt es
schon mal hinzuschauen das ist eine
besorgniserregende entwicklung also
einen journalismus der eigentlich immer
erst in dem moment kommt wo alle sehen
können dass es schief gelaufen ist
verfehlt aus meiner sicht im grunde
seinen wesentlichen zweck und deswegen
gilt ganz genau das was georg kestel
gerade gesagt hat ich glaube ohnehin das
schreibtischen ziemlich gefährlicher ort
für eine journalistin oder ein
journalist an dem man nicht so viel zeit
verbringen sollte und ich glaube dass
wir ein missverhältnis haben zwischen
all den die oder das führt zu weniger
haben die einfach unterwegs sind die
draußen sind die neugierig sind die zu
hören die ihnen verständnis für
unterschiedliche journalismus eine große
konkurrenz
das muss ich jetzt schon sagen dass die
ard jetzt in kiew es hat eine weile
gedauert bis die ard hat ihr präsent war
also
ich bin sehr gut dass er jetzt da ist
aber
somit mit mit
mutig war die agenda der rest da direkt
mal selbst das ist jetzt das
muss man jetzt mal an bin aber dann soll
der hesse das auch bitte selbst bald
darauf reagiert moment
die frage
ich spreche nicht würde ja die ich kann
für mich sprechen und ich kann nur sagen
dass jetzt sehen sie mal meinen freunden
und angehörigen dass das mutlos sei was
wir hier machen was das team mehr macht
und ich muss sagen wir sind ja seit
insgesamt jetzt fünf wochen mit einem
tollen team unterwegs mit dem kameramann
unterwegs mit einem cutter unterwegs mit
producer unterwegs sie in diesem land
das sind mutige leute das sind tolle
leute die dafür sorgen dass die menschen
in deutschland gute informationen über
diesen krieg gekommen zuerst in der west
ukraine und jetzt in kiew und ich bin
sehr froh mit diesen menschen hier zu
sein und das ist eine tolle arbeit die
die hier machen wie übrigens viele viele
andere kollegen und kolleginnen
medien nicht nur öffentlich rechtlicher
medien auch für dich ja größten respekt
ab und das bescheuerte an der ganzen
debatte wäre wenn wir jetzt hier unter
den journalisten und unter journalisten
hier sich hier bekriegen würden oder
sich vor war vorwerfen würden wer hier
näher oder weniger nah dran ist ich habe
einen großen respekt vor all den aus
ihrem haus dem haus axel springer die
sich früh auf den weg gemacht haben ich
sehe wirklich viel außerordentlich
interessante gute berichterstattung vor
dem letzten schlagabtausch war oder wird
wer ja ich glaube alle die da sind ja
sind mutig und vor allem sehr wichtig
die arbeit die sie da tun ich würde
gerne jetzt zum schluss noch mal diese
eine runde machen frau koelbl jetzt
haben wir natürlich schon wissen auch
eine konkurrenz durch social media und
da wird ganz viel wird ganz viel an
inhalten verbreitet wo sehen sie dann
punkt gerade jetzt halt eben auch in
dieser kriegsberichterstattung wie man
da sich aufstellen sollte also das sonst
linie ist es ja es ist ja so dass es
quasi eine echtzeit berichterstattung
gibt wie sie vorher nicht gegeben hat
das ist alles gleichzeitig information
ist es verwirrend es ist es ist eine
chance und das ist auch eine chance für
propaganda im grunde ist das ein
schnelleres medium wie meinetwegen
in all den kriegen in den letzten 100
jahren aber aber aber dass der
mechanismus ist es ist glaube ich dir
gleich erlauben sie mir glauben sie mir
trotzdem noch einen eine einen aspekt
über die sogenannte propaganda die
propaganda ist in russland sicherlich
extrem und sehr gut gesteuert die leute
könnten wissen vielleicht man braucht
ein vpn-tunnel natürlich aber hier in
diesem land wohnen zwei millionen russen
von diesen zwei millionen russen haben
alle zugang zu allen informationen und
trotzdem hat eine absolute mehrheit die
gleiche haltung wie die russen in
russland die wiederum abgeschnitten sind
davon das heißt also und ob das jetzt
social media ist oder ob das
fernsehsender sie ist jede art von
information offensichtlich ist der
faktor tiefer gehend und sitzt er in den
politischen fragen und den
identitätsfragen als in den medialen
frage also man letztendlich dann doch
auf was wir schon gesprochen haben will
irgendwie das hören was man hören will
und oder nicht richtig hinsehen zum
schluss noch etwas auf was stellen sie
sich ein in diesen nächsten wochen wenn
wir noch mehr es schreckliche bilder
sehen noch mehr von diesen ereignissen
gibt es ein punkt wo man sagt da kann
der kriegt man dann noch mal eine ganz
andere wendung nehmen also für mich
endet am 24 februar
die seiten wir wissen das nicht und ich
kann nur
warnen vor dem glauben dass der krieg
schnell vorbei ist
alle die sich intensiv mit russland aus
den entsprechenden kreisen beschäftigen
sehen ganz klar die eskalation dominanz
computing und sehen auch die
bereitschaft jetzt nicht für den
globalen atomkrieg aber durchaus den
einsatz taktischer atomwaffen als
warnung um ein politisches ergebnis zu
erzwingen und ich bin in großer sorge
weil putin hatte nicht die letzte
militärische karte gespielt und wir
wissen es natürlich nicht aber
der krieg wird militärisch so oder so
entschieden werden das dann wird
wirklich verhandelt und noch sind wir an
diesem punkt leider nicht also ich bin
ehrlich gesagt ein großer sorge auch
wegen des referenz- datums neu dabei die
siegesfeier und da was zu präsentieren
also wir wissen es nicht ich hoffe es
nicht aber ich muss leider befürchten
dass hier noch viele schreckliche bilder
aus der ukraine sind
habe ich das neue semester das war nicht
an sie gerichtet und ich finde es
grundsätzlich gut und richtig indem er
journalistinnen und journalisten aus
öffentlich rechtlichen oder privaten vom
spiegel von der welt von wem auch immer
vor ort sind
umso besser ist es glaube ich für uns
alle und auch zu machen ganz genau
zuhöre und deswegen das war wirklich
nicht an sie
gerichteten rechtlich gegen springer
nicht diese prognose aber da ich glaube
es ist wichtig damit dass der journalist
stärken und was wir auch journalisten
natürlich auch in der ukraine stärken
also ukrainische journalisten wie jetzt
eben auch fliehen mussten dass der die
auch nicht werken das ist eben auch ganz
wichtig ganz herzlichen dank für diese
diskussion ganz herzlichen dank ihnen
georg restle alles gute für die arbeit
passen auch sie bitte auf sich auf weil
sie dank youtube
neitzel hamas colo an herzlichen dank
ihnen fürs zuschauen hier bei der
phoenix runde 25 jahre phoenix das ist
unser jubiläum am 7 14 vor 25 jahren
wurde dieser sender gegründet bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]